>> Phoebe Connelly:
Good afternoon.
I'm Phoebe Connelly, the
deputy director of video
at the Washington Post.
We are a charter sponsor of
the National Book Festival.
I'd like to start by thanking
the co-chairman of the festival,
David Rubenstein, and the
other generous sponsors
who have made this
event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
is in our program.
We will have time after the
presentation for questions
and have been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone you will
be included in videotape
of the event which may be
broadcast at a later time.
So, without further ado,
our guests today are Matt
De La Peña and Loren Long.
They are the author and
illustrator of this book,
"Love", which they will
be talking about today.
Matt de la Pena is the number
one New York Times bestselling
Newberry Medal-winning author
of 5 picture books including
"The Last Stop on Market
Street", and his new one
which is coming out shortly
called "Carmela Full of Wishes",
as well as 6 critically
acclaimed young adult novels.
He received his MFA
in creative writing
for San Diego State University
and he attended school
on a full athletic
scholarship for basketball,
which I think is a
pretty cool fact.
Lauren Long is the award winning
number one New York Times
bestselling children's book
author and illustrator.
He is the creator of the Otis
series of picture books as well
as Little Tree and the upcoming
"There's a Hole in the Log
at the Bottom of the Lake".
You might also know his drawings
because he's the illustrator
of "Of Thee I Sing"
by Barack Obama.
Before they get them started,
they will be signing
books at 2:00 pm.
So, please welcome Matt
de la Peña and Loren Long.
[ Applause ]
>> Matt de la Peña: Hello, guys.
Thank you so much
for having us here.
The last time I was
here I think, Loren,
too, it was on the lawn.
>> Loren Long: Yeah,
it was outside.
>> Matt de la Peña: This is
the first time they've done
it inside.
This is exciting.
We're going to begin by just
reading the book to you.
Ready? You might notice
Loren over here drawing.
He seems to draw
everywhere we go.
So, Love.
In the beginning, there is light
and two wide eyed figures
standing near the foot
of your bed, and the sound
of their voices is love.
A cab driver plays love softly
on his radio while you bounce
in back with the bumps of the
city and everything smells new.
And, it smells like life.
Love too, is the smell
of crashing waves
and a train whistling
blindly in the distance.
And, each night the sky
above your trailer
turns the color of love.
In a crowded concrete park you
toddle toward summer sprinklers
while older kids skip
rope and run up the slide.
And, soon you are running
among them and the echo
of your laughter is love.
On the night the fire alarm
blares you're pulled from sleep
and whisked into the street
where a quiet old lady
is pointing to the sky.
Stars shine long after they've
flamed out," she tells you,
"and the shine they
shine with is love."
But it's not only stars that
flame out, you discover.
It's summers too, and
friendships and people.
One day, you find your family
nervously huddled around the TV
but when you asked
what happened,
they answer with
silence and shift
between you and the screen.
In your dream that
night, you are searching
for a love that seems lost.
You open and close
drawers, lift cushions,
empty old toy bins,
but there's nothing.
You wake with a start in the
arms of a loved one who bends
to your ear and whispers,
"It's okay, it's okay."
It's love.
And, in time you learn to
recognize a love overlooked.
A love that wakes at dawn
and rides to work on the bus.
A slice of burned toast
that tastes like love.
And, it's love in
each deep crease
of your grandfather's
face as he lowers himself
onto an overturned
bucket to fish.
And, it's love in
the rustling leaves
of gnarled trees lined
behind the flower fields.
And, it's love in the made
up stories your uncles tell
in the backyard between
wild horseshoe throws.
And, the mad in rags outside the
subway station plays love notes
that lift into the sky
like tiny beacons of light.
And, the face staring back
in the bathroom mirror?
This, too, is love.
So, when the time comes for
you to set off on your own,
heavy winds will sweep past
your building and great,
great clouds will
congregate above.
Your loved ones will stand there
like puddles beneath their
umbrellas holding you tight
and kissing you and
wishing you luck.
But, it won't be
luck you'll leave
with because you'll have love.
You'll have love, love, love.
Thank you for letting
me read that to you.
[ Applause ]
And, now what we're going
to do is we're going
to just briefly talk
about where we come from
and how we both arrived
at this same book.
Loren lives in Cincinnati, Ohio.
I live in Brooklyn, New York.
So, we're coming at it
from different places,
different upbringings.
And, we wanted to find the most
inclusive word we could render
in a book and for
us it was love.
So, a little bit about me first.
This is my dad.
He was a just a kid
when I was born.
He was the first in his
family to be born in America.
We call him the Mexican Hippie
Surfer because he's Mexican
but he likes to surf,
which is not normal.
And, that's me, the big boy
right there, that liked tacos.
So, my dad's Mexican,
my mom's white.
Now, this isn't the
greatest picture of me.
By the way I thought that there
was an undiagnosed medical
condition happening here until I
just had a son a few months ago
and he's even fatter than me.
So, it's just purely genetic.
But, here's my mom and they were
both teenagers when I was born
and we grew up right
on the Mexican border.
And, I did play basketball
in college.
I became the first
in my family to go
to college thanks to a sport.
That's why all you young guys
if you love sports it
could take you places
that you never imagined.
I'm just going to flash through
a couple of my previous books,
Last Stop on Market Street.
[Applause] That's nice.
Where did I come out
on landing on Love?
I just remember there
was so much divisiveness
in the country, you know, when
I started to write the book.
And, I had a daughter
at the time.
Only a daughter, and I remember
thinking, "What is the one thing
that we all share no matter
our political beliefs,
no matter what our social
standing in the country is?"
And, I felt like it's love.
It's the kid growing up in
Brooklyn has love hopefully.
The kid growing up in
rural Pennsylvania has love
in their family.
So, that's where I
landed with this book.
And, I was very fortunate
enough to be able
to share this experience
with Loren Long.
And, now he's going to tell you
a little about his background.
>> Loren Long: Alright,
so Matt de la Peña grew
up near the ocean.
In San Diego, near the
Mexican border in an exotic,
wave place where people surf.
I came from an exotic
land called Missouri.
There's my childhood.
So, it was one of the best
things about doing the book
and actually collaborating
with the author is
getting to know him.
I really learned a lot about his
culture by sharing my culture.
You can see what I look like.
Here's my dad and my mom.
Nobody in my family
were artists, you know?
They liked, so this is Missouri,
then we moved to Kentucky.
This is when you're
an 11 year old kid
on your birthday your mom
might put a horse when you live
in Lexington, Kentucky.
We didn't wear shirts or shoes.
No Kentucky jokes.
Now I live in Ohio, but it was
really wonderful for me to grow
up in this environment.
A couple of teachers.
We have educators in the
room by show of hands?
Yes, yes, a couple
of special teachers.
By this time, mom
and dad salesperson,
secretary, no artists.
We didn't go to art museums.
We didn't do those things.
The only time we went
to an art museum is
when we visited my
grandmother in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
And, we went to this, I used
to call it the Cowboy Museum.
It was the Gilcrease Hills
Museum, Tulsa, Oklahoma.
It was filled with Frederic
Remington paintings.
I wasn't an artist,
but I loved to draw
and I had a couple
of special teachers.
This is my middle school,
my seventh grade influential
human being in my life.
And, I'll go ahead and straight
up just tell you it was a mostly
white school that I went to.
Seventh grade, this man was
the head football coach.
He was the coolest
guy in the building.
He would never know shrimpy
Loren who was the furthest thing
from a football coach except
he was also the art teacher.
I heard him say my name once
and I looked up and I said,
"I can't believe Mr.
Pennington uttered my name.
And, he was holding my drawing.
And, I'll never forget the sound
of hearing Mr. Pennington
use my name
and it's just an amazing thing.
That was love.
He didn't have to help me out
but he started giving me
a little extra attention.
By the way, I was never the
best artist in my class.
There was always some annoying
kids that were better than me.
But, I really loved it.
I really loved it.
Then, I had another
teacher, Miss Clifton.
I'll never forget Miss
Clifton to the day I die.
By the way, that's me
with all that hair.
That's me as a, like a
freshman or a 10th grader.
She's teaching me how
to use oil paints.
She was bringing her
art books from home.
"Loren, this is Vincent
Van Gogh,
have you ever heard of him?
Loren, have you ever
heard of Norman Rockwell?"
So it was very influential.
I've come all these
years to realize
that was absolutely an
act of love on her part.
Here's some of my books.
One of the biggest joys
of my careers is illustrating
The Little Engine That Could,
one of my favorite
songs when I was little.
We'll go through these quick.
Otis The Tractor was the
first thing I ever wrote.
I never thought I
would write something.
I wasn't a great reader
when I was little.
It was an attention thing.
It was easier for me to draw
pictures and play and goof
around than it was
to focus on reading.
So, as a result I never thought
I would grow up and be a writer,
and I wrote my own story
about a little tractor.
And, we have six
hardcovers by the way.
They make great gifts.
And, yeah, the kid
from Lexington,
Kentucky gets this phone call.
President Obama, yes!
[ Applause ]
I'm living in Cincinnati,
Ohio, and somebody
from New York calls me
because the president
and his family chose me
to illustrate his amazing
love letter to his daughters,
Of Thee I Sing, A
Letter to my Daughters.
At that point, check
that one out.
And, Little Tree.
When my sons, who I feel like
are your age, went to college,
I was having a hard
time with it.
My wife wasn't even having
as hard a time as I was.
For some reason, it was
hard for me to let go
and I wrote a little fable.
And, who knows that I
could write something
but it actually gave me comfort.
And, I thought if
it comforted me,
maybe it would comfort
somebody else.
So, Little Tree.
And, then I think
we're on Love, right?
>> Matt de la Peña:
Yeah, we are.
>> Loren Long: And, then
Love, and then I get this.
This is called the manuscript.
So, Matt de la Peña
lives in New York,
I live in Cincinnati, Ohio.
I had been fortunate
enough to meet Matt.
I knew about his career.
I knew of his Newbery
Medal career and I get
in my phone call from my agent,
a text called Love,
from Matt de la Peña.
I read this and I'm
thinking, "I'm in."
I want to give Love
to the world.
And, then I read it
and Matt's text went
into some different places.
I'll never forget the first time
I read this piece right here
and I said, and I read, "The sky
above your trailer turns
the color of love."
And, I actually said, "Did he
say 'trailer?'" And, I'm like,
"This goes into different
areas."
This book allowed me to take
my art, my Otis The Tractor
and Little Engine
That Could career,
into a little different area.
And, I'll always be
grateful for that, Matt.
In Matt's text he talks
about how beautiful love is,
how you receive it, how
you start to recognize it.
It's also a little
messy in places right?
Love isn't always perfect.
And, I said, "You know I've been
painting the same way my entire
career for 15 books.
It's time for me to do
something a little different."
So, has anybody ever heard
of monoprints, monotypes?
What I did with Love,
it's unpredictable.
I have a way of painting
my art into oblivion.
People have to tell
me to stop, you know?
Nobody ever has to say,
"Loren, paint more."
They always have to say, "Stop."
Right art directors, editors?
Because I'm like a working
artist, I'm going to work
on this painting until I
prove this thing is good
to the world every time,
even after I've illustrated
Barack Obama's book.
I'm still having
to prove myself.
Anyway, I sometimes get a little
too detailed to so I decided
to do monotype prints.
So, I'm looking at, okay
so first I'm looking
at the manuscript.
There's no book, right?
It's just paper, and this
is what I'm looking at.
And, I'm pretending I'm a movie
director and this is the part
where it says, Matt, can
you read that for me?
>> Matt de la Peña: Sure,
it's, "And in time you learn
to recognize love overlooked,
a love that wakes at dawn
and rides to work on the bus."
And, originally the
line after that read,
"A pair of old house
slippers that fit like love."
And I was thinking
of my grandmother.
>> Loren Long: So,
you took this text.
So, if you all got that
text what would you draw?
That's what I'm asking myself.
I feel like I'm five years
old again drawing Snoopy
on the kitchen floor.
There's no difference.
So, I decide I'm going to make
a moment in this little movie
and I'm going to show
the child from behind
and he's watching his parents.
That bus represents his parents
and I thought how clever am I?
I'm going to put oversized
slippers and I'm going
to nail this and the slippers
represent the parents.
But, when I saw the picture
it didn't ring true to me.
It almost felt like a desertion,
like someone is being deserted.
It was too heavy.
It wasn't the right note.
It wasn't the right
moment in our movie.
So, I changed it.
You can see here I've
changed the socioeconomic
of this little boy simply by the
props that I put in his room.
Now, I've got a big
picture window, right?
I've got kind of a different
type of fancy drapes.
I'm still grappling
with what kind
of underwear this little
boy is going to wear.
>> Matt de la Peña:
The tighty whitey here?
>> Loren Long: Yeah, this
is the tighty whitey here,
the blue and gold.
>> Matt de la Peña: And,
apparently your wife
was not a fan.
>> Loren Long: No, my
wife by the way comes
into my studio, which
is in my home.
And, she says, "I don't
like the tighty whiteys."
And, I'm saying, "This
is authentic, man.
Tracy, this is art!"
Yeah, so you can see here
I also put the figure.
I put the parent
walking to that bus.
And, then I felt like
it wasn't quite right.
I remembered my own
brother at a time
when my two parents left before
we did for the school bus.
My brother, my oldest brother's
responsibility was feeding me.
And, he would always make toast.
And, so I brought
in another figure.
You see I've made
the windows smaller.
I've changed what kind of
subject I'm making just
by those little details.
>> Matt de la Peña: And, so
this gets kicked over to me
and I think this is
an interesting detail.
Not everybody knows, normally
when a picture book is created,
the author and the
illustrator stay separate.
They never discuss
any of the process.
They only meet when
the book is done.
But, Loren and I had
a different situation.
We actually talked on
the phone multiple times.
We talked out everything.
And, when I got this
sketch in the mail
or in my email I
actually thought whoa,
this is a whole other
layer of Love
that I hadn't originally
considered.
And, for the first time
in my career I changed the
text because of a sketch.
So, I took out the oversized
slippers that I thought
of my grandmother, I
remember from her closet.
And, I said you know what, I'm
going to put this toast in.
So, it changed the line to,
"A slice of burned toast
that tastes like love."
>> Loren Long: And, that's
my favorite line in the book.
>> Matt de la Peña: Of course.
>> Loren Long: It
is a good line.
>> Matt de la Peña:
It's a great line.
That's a great piece of writing.
>> Loren Long: It was
actually cited in a review
and I was like, "Can I
take credit for this?"
>> Matt de la Peña:
Well yeah, you can.
>> Loren Long: So,
just real quick,
in part because of what I
told you about me being a bit
of a perfectionist, I
wanted to do monoprints.
Instead of taking my paint
from my palette directly
to the illustration board or
the canvas, we used a brayer
and worked on glass, plexiglass.
And, for you monotype
specialists out here,
forgive me this is the first
time I've ever done this,
because I was trying
to jump in the dark.
I was trying to do something to
match the depth of Matt's text.
So, I would ink up the
brayer and I would wipe it
on to the plexiglass and
smudge it away and pull it away
and use paintbrushes to add,
use Q-tips to pull away and draw
and manipulate the ink.
Then I would take it down to a
studio and then I would take it
down to the little makeshift
basement printing shop
that I set up.
I convinced my wife
I should buy a press.
Put this on, and then took a
piece of paper that was damp,
put it down, run it
through that roller
and it actually mashes
the ink onto that paper.
You come out and you
pull that paper up
and it has an impression.
And, that doesn't look like much
but I thought okay,
those are my figures.
That's my figures, but I
can't do the background.
So, I did that on another
page and you can see the one
on the right is a real
dark background, the wall.
And, I'm having fun.
It's like I can never paint
these textures with my hand
and paintbrush like I've
been doing for 20 years.
But, I did something
called a ghost print.
That background is too dark, so
I ran that same piece of glass
through on a new clean piece of
paper and I got the lighter one.
And, then, how many of
you guys do collage art?
I'd never done collage
art, but I needed
to to put these images together.
So, I cut the window from the
right, glued it onto the left,
cut he figures out, cut
them out, glued them on,
and I've got my painting.
It doesn't look finished,
but I've got the
structure of my art.
I've got stuff that I'd never
done with textures and rawness
that I thought sort
of matched the text
about love in Matt's work.
And, then here I finished by
painting like I always do,
with paint brushes and
some color pencils,
putting extra attention on the
expression, just a little touch
in this big brother, his face.
But you want to get
that emotion right.
And, then, Matt, you saw this.
>> Matt de la Peña: Yes.
>> Loren Long: This
is when you--
>> Matt de la Peña:
This is probably
when I actually changed the
text and you might notice
that this is pretty well
made toast and I was like,
"I don't trust this brother's
toast making skills."
So, I burned it and now
watch the final detail.
He burns it.
>> Loren Long: Yeah, that was an
all-nighter to burn that toast.
>> Matt de la Peña: But,
you know we would just
like to say it's such an honor
to share this book with you
at the National Book Festival.
So, thank you so
much for having us.
>> Loren Long: I
have one thing to do.
>> Matt de la Peña: Yeah,
and then Loren actually has
something he's produced here.
So, if you're an
educator raise your hands.
I see we have a lot
of educators.
>> Loren Long: Who's in
an elementary school?
What are you?
You're a reading teacher?
Okay, what's your name?
Christina, do you
have a classroom?
Do you have walls?
Alright, your name is, how
do you spell your name?
Okay, I might misspell
it but here we go.
>> Matt de la Peña:
So, it's kind of cool
because he's given these out
everywhere we've presented.
>> Loren Long: I-N-A, right?
>> Matt de la Peña:
It's kind of fun.
>> Loren Long: Thank you guys.
I'm just going to sign
this and give it to you.
>> Matt de la Peña: Thank you.